you
happy holidays hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen back for
another round of pantry staples now
pumpkin pie is a real favor on my
holiday spread but so many recipes call
for less than a full can of the pumpkin
puree what is with that why isn't there
a universal pumpkin pie ratio that
perfectly corresponds to the contents of
a pumpkin puree can am I the only one
that finds us to be an incredible
inconvenience thankfully I've spent a
lot of time reflecting on this and as a
result I've come up with some pretty
tasty solutions let's get started try in
your vegetarian quesadillas with your
favorite veggies and cheese I like black
beans corn avocado bell peppers and
cheddar
try making pumpkin pie pancakes by
adding half a cup of pumpkin puree and
some pumpkin pie spice to your favorite
pancake recipe and why not try a pumpkin
shrimp curry by having a few heaping
tablespoons to your favorite curry sauce
see and you thought pumpkin was just for
making pumpkin pie if you've got fun
creative ways to use up your canned
pumpkin leave me a comment down below
thanks so much for watching guys more
great inspiration for getting creative
and healthy in the kitchen this holiday
be sure to subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
you